وأكد زميل رئيس الوزراء الروسي
التعاون يحتاج إلى تعزيز
دولة الاتحاد وفي اجتماع
ناقشت الحكومات كيفية تعاملها
[موسيقى]
ما يحدث في أوكرانيا
جريمة
[موسيقى]
يكمن الحسد في ضمير واحد فقط
الرجل وهذا الرجل فلاديمير بوتين
والدي أوكراني والدتي روسية وهم
لم يكن أبدا أعداء وهذه القلادة
على رقبتي كرمز لواقع روسيا
يجب أن يتوقف على الفور
الحرب بين الأخوة والأخوة لدينا
الشعوب وما زالت قادرة على ذلك للأسف
عملت السنوات الماضية على الأول
قناة تشارك في دعاية الكرملين
وأنا الآن أشعر بالخجل الشديد من ذلك
للسماح بالتحدث بالأكاذيب
شاشة التلفزيون تخجل من حقيقة ذلك
مسموح
أنا ممتن لأولئك الروس الذين لم يفعلوا ذلك
توقف عن محاولة نقلها إلى أولئك الذين
يحارب المعلومات المضللة ويحكي
قل الحقيقة الحقائق الحقيقية لك
أصدقاء لأقاربهم المقربين وشخصيا لذلك
الفتاة التي دخلت الاستوديو أولاً
قناة مع ملصق ضد الحرب